foreign
[Music]
to share with you another original from
the science fiction genre after nearly a
year since the theatrical release of the
first part today we bring you our
updated movie preview of Dune part 2. we
will cover lots of events from the books
from the feature film and from David
Lynch's old film so there is a
correspondingly high risk of spoilers of
course but here's everything you need to
know about the plot cast and production
so pay attention and enjoy our new
original episode
in June we were already introduced to
the gigantic Universe during the almost
two and a half hour duration the story
takes place in the year 10191 and deals
with the power struggle for control over
the Galactic Empire of mankind the focus
is on Paula treadise a smart young man
who cannot quite grasp yet what his
great Destiny will turn out to be the
son of Lady Jessica and Duke Leto at
tradies the first is not really finding
his way around his new home planet of a
rockets and is soon confronted with the
death of his father and his escape with
his mother from the forces of the
Hostile harkinen family at the end of
the film he meets the girl Cheney whom
he had previously only seen in his
dreams and joined the native Freeman
these are a kind of subculture of humans
who consider the planet Iraqis their
home the ending of part one is not as
abrupt as it might seem at first given
the large-scale story the first movie
covered roughly half of Herbert's book
Dune and concludes when house Atreides
is more or less non-existent and it
looks like an outnumbered battle a
ritual by which Paul and his mother gain
the respect of the Freeman has already
been depicted in the film Hall fights
Jamis in a knife fight until death as
the laws of the Freeman demand and the
second ritual on the other hand did not
occur which is why we assume that we
will see it at the beginning of June 2.
this time is the turn of Paul's mother
Jessica as she has to drink from the
Water of Life however contrary to its
euphonious name The Wonder of life is
not a tasty magic potion but the
poisonous excretion of a young sand worm
drowned in water the procedure has to do
with the beliefs of the Freeman because
worms play a major role there they are
characterized by a great Duality since
the worm can represent both God and
Satan by drinking the water she becomes
the Reverend mother of the free men a
kind of spiritual leader as Reverend
mother she must then transform the water
into a harmless drug that the Freeman
enjoy to consume at their Gatherings but
how does the story go on in Dune 2 those
who read the books will know that after
Jessica's ritual there is a big time
Jump here directorville news should be
particularly careful not to rush the
story after all that was one of the
major flaws of the first movie
adaptation from 1984 so it may well be
that they will take their time to depict
the arrival and further life of Paul and
Jessica with the Freeman in particular
we have in mind the birth of Paul's
sister Aaliyah who has already gained
Consciousness in her mother's womb
through the water ritual and possesses
special powers she is also the girl with
blue eyes of whom Paul had some Visions
because of his successful fight against
Jameis Paul is called usul by tribe
leader stillgar it is translated as the
strength of the base of the pillar
stillgar will later become a loyal
companion and important advisor to the
main character the final acceptance by
the free men is then also expressed in a
completely new name for Paul and that is
muadib in contrast to usul this is his
common name with which everyone
addresses him from now on actually in
Arabic a similar word means teacher a
second story aspect that unfortunately
comes up far too short in the book is
the initial love affair between Paul and
Cheney which also took its course during
the Greek time Jump one could certainly
fill hours with the development of Paul
and Cheney's relationship until the
birth of their first child however the
challenge will be to find the balance
between a debauched love story and
interesting story details either way the
book picks up quite late after the time
Jump In addition to his personal family
happiness Paul grows more more into a
leader position among the Freeman and is
initially not yet developed strength
also becomes increasingly powerful he is
seen by the Freeman as the great savior
that has been repeatedly prophecied to
them and many of the visions that have
long haunted Paul will also eventually
coalesce particularly with all the spice
the Freeman consume Paul's Powers
continue to increase as a result Paul
becomes sort of overpowering and is
capable of looking into the past and the
future as well as seeing all the events
of the universe at the same time it will
be a special treat to see Paul writing
the true fan favorites later in the film
namely the sand worms when he then also
drinks the Water of Life which can
actually only be survived by women his
powers will complete and he will be
ready to finally face Baron harkinen
interesting is the future of the
character Gurney Hallock embodied by
Thanos actor Josh Brolin the Duke's
armorer is also Paul's trainer and has
trained him for the adverse conditions
of the desert Planet he will return in
the upcoming film as will the Atreides
mentat thur fear hawat played by Stephen
McKinley Henderson in the book hauwata's
leader forced into service by Baron
Harkin as his own mentat Peter DeVries
was in fact killed by Duke Leto due to a
mix-up a different fate happens to
Gurney as he surprisingly survives the
big battle and devotes himself to a life
as a spice Smuggler in the course of the
story he also meets Paul and Jessica
again who let's say he is not too fond
of particularly with the latter he finds
himself at odds there are also many
presumed Dead with questionable Fates on
the one hand there's the planetary
ecologist leap kinds who appears for the
first time as a Woman in real news film
adaptation unlike in the book and in the
1984 film according to the book she is
indeed dead but then again the question
can be raised whether vilnew perhaps
recast her for the reason of having her
appear in the second part as well in any
case the director can be credited with
that much artistic freedom in a movie
adaptation that is otherwise very close
to the book even more likely is a
reappearance of Duncan Idaho who was
killed in the attack on a raucous
despite his passing the likable
character who is played by Jason Momoa
at least appears to have a future in the
world imagined by Frank Herbert he no
longer appears in the old Dune film but
he does celebrate his return as Gola in
the second book strictly speaking
however Duncan is no longer alive
because agola is an artificially created
human being who preserves the memories
of an individual and thus lets him live
on in a certain way his return has not
been denied nor confirmed yet someone
who is missing from the book is Chatham
IV the emperor of the entire universe
and undoubtedly one of the most powerful
figures the comparison to David Lynch's
movie is interesting here because there
the emperor has a regular appearance
quite a few casting possibilities
circulated on the net from Michael
Fassbender and Jared Harris to mans
Mickelson and Ray fines the slim elegant
man with the cold eyes described in the
book would have been a perfect fit for
many actors but in the end it was
Christopher Walken a legendary actor
known for his dark and often just
disturbing rolls who was cast as
important as the role of the emperor is
that of his eldest daughter princess
arul and Corrido she acts as a historian
and narrates the events surrounding Paul
Atreides during the course of the story
she even officially becomes Paul's wife
however the marriage was only done for
convenience and happened on the orders
of her father and as a result they have
no Offspring she is to be played by
Midsummer actress Florence Pugh who even
Bears a certain resemblance to actress
Virginia Madsen from the 1984 movie
version also recast was the role of Lady
Margot she is part of the Benny Jesuit
the wife of mentat has a mere fenring
and an ally of Paul she supports him in
his quest to avenge the house of
Atreides she'll be portrayed by Bond
girl Leia sedu in addition to Florence
Pugh Christopher Walken and Leia sedu
Elvis actor Austin Butler also joins the
cast The 31 year old plays the ruthless
and cruel fade wratha harkinet who is
the younger nephew of Baron Vladimir in
David Lynch's film by the way he was
embodied by none other than the police
front Man Sting the latest addition to
the cast is the Swiss actress suhaila
yako who has previously made a name for
herself mostly in French Cinema she
plays the character shishokly who is the
rather tough squad leader of the fedikan
a part of The Siege Tabor all things
considered it can be said that Dune part
1 takes place in a relatively short
period of time compared to the possible
plot of part two the difficulty with the
sequel is making a meaningful connection
between the end of the first movie and
the beginning of the second between Paul
and Jessica's joining the Freeman and
the big attack on the Barrett or even
the emperor later on a fair amount of
time passes in between vilnuv has to
accommodate a gigantic plethora of
events or at least cut them down enough
in order to do justice to the scope of
the book and an adequate big screen
Adventure at the same time Jessica has
to face the ritual Paul becomes muadib
and learns to ride sand worms and then
simultaneously they have to prepare for
the grand finale of the second part and
include many of the aforementioned
characters
filming started in Budapest in July 2022
after completing preliminary shoots in
Italy there the Tomba brione was used as
a setting which is originally a family
tomb in a memorial at the same time
Carlos scarpa's architecture was very
reminiscent of the brutalist style of
the buildings in Dune making it an ideal
set it is not yet known exactly when
filming will be completed but it is not
expected to last too long after the
success of the first part the director
is again denieville new who also wrote
the screenplay together with Jon Spitz
and Eric Roth much to the Delight of
many fans there is one more returnee who
is neither an actor nor a part of the
crew this is star composer Hans Zimmer
who is the number one choice for epic
soundtracks and who has agreed to take
over the musical aspects of the second
film as well we are definitely very
excited about Dune part 2 and look
forward to the planned release in just
about a year on November 3rd 2023
this was our new original for Dune part
2. which characters would you like to
see in addition to the ones mentioned
earlier and which events from the book
should not be missing in your opinion
feel free to tell us in the comments
[Music]
[Music]